Hallo und willkommen zu diesem "Q&A"
zu meiner Reportage
"Influencerin im Namen Gottes"
In den vergangenen Monaten
besuchte ich zwei Frauen,
die auf Instagram, TikTok und Youtube
für Gott influencen,
also ihre Nachricht
weitergeben wollen.
Einerseits besuchte ich Mirja,
eine reformierte Pfarrerin,
und andererseits Maimouna,
die für den Islamischen Zentralrat
Content erstellt.
Falls du die Reportage noch
nicht gesehen hast, schau sie jetzt.
Am Schluss der Reportage fragten wir:
Was meint ihr?
Ist das legitim, ist das okay?
Sollen sie das doch machen?
Oder haben Religion
und religiöse Influencerinnen
in eurem Feed gar nichts zu suchen?
Logisch erreichten uns
verschiedene Sachen, z.B.:
Und das hier
geht in dieselbe Richtung:
Diese Meinung ist absolut legitim,
ich sehe das auch ein bisschen so.
Die Grenze wird für mich erreicht,
wenn Dinge vermittelt werden,
die nicht in Ordnung sind,
die in der Glaubensart
zu radikal sind.
Egal, welche Religion.
Das finde ich nicht in Ordnung.
Aber Angelina schreibt auch:
"Wieso kann man andere Leute
nicht in Ruhe lassen?"
"Wieso muss man missionieren?"
Bei den beiden Frauen,
die ich besuchte, habe ich gemerkt,
sie sind so überzeugt.
Sie sind wirklich
von der Botschaft Gottes überzeugt.
Sie haben das Gefühl, Gott sei super.
Die Botschaft Gottes helfe einem
weiter, also müsse man das auch ...
Sie machen das aus tiefstem Glauben.
Faladissima schreibt:
"Einerseits finde ich es bedenklich,
ihnen eine Plattform zu bieten."
"Andererseits sieht
und hört man wenigstens selbst,
welchen Blödsinn sie erzählen."
Ja, das stimmt, das hat etwas.
Als ich mit der Wissenschaftlerin
der Universität Luzern
über den IZRS sprach,
sprachen wir darüber,
ob man das verbieten sollte,
z.B. wenn sie auf Social Media
zu radikal sind.
Sie sagte dann,
das sei logisch eine Option,
also eine juristische Frage,
andererseits sei es ja auch gut,
das man sieht, was läuft. Damit
nicht alles im Untergrund versickert.
Das hat etwas,
was Faladissima hier sagt.
Wir besuchten
zwei total verschiedene Frauen.
Wir gehen jetzt ins IZRS zu Maimouna,
die wir besuchten.
Dort kam in mehreren Kommentaren
das Thema auf,
wie z.B. hier bei Jason:
Wenn du schaust,
was sie auf Social Media posten,
oder wie viele Leute sie erreichen,
dann sind sie eben doch relevant.
Das geht in die Richtung
von Faladissimas Kommentar:
Wir können sie einfach ignorieren,
aber es ist wichtig,
genau dann hinzuschauen,
v.a. wenn sie umstritten sind.
Deshalb entschieden wir uns dazu,
das zu tun.
Aber toll, dass das Thema aufkommt
und wir darüber reden können.
José schreibt auch in diese Richtung:
Die Wissenschaftlerin der Uni Luzern,
Silvia Martens,
forschte ganz aktuell
über Salafismus in der Schweiz.
Es wird von 400-1'100 Menschen
in der Deutschweiz ausgegangen,
die so glauben wie Maimouna
und die Leute des IZRS.
D.h., es ist wirklich
eine krasse Minderheit.
Wir besuchten eine Minderheit,
du hast recht.
Aber da sie so viele Leute
erreichen, finde ich es okay.
Sonst hätten wir es nicht gemacht.
Ich erwähnte im Film extra,
dass sie eine Minderheit sind,
dass man sich
dessen bewusst sein muss.
Ich hoffe, dass die Zuschauer/-innen
das begriffen haben. Ich hoffe es.
Acucena schreibt:
Richtig.
Auch innerhalb des Islams gibt es
verschiedene Glaubensrichtungen,
wie auch innerhalb des Christentums.
Es ist einfach das,
was mir auf Social Media auffiel.
Apropos Mirja:
Sie ist ja v.a. auf Instagram tätig,
und auf Instagram
ist sie nicht die Einzige,
die für Gott,
für die Kirche, für die Religion
influenct und Content erstellt.
Ich habe mich
mit Aline Knapp verabredet,
sie arbeitete an einer Studie
zur Followerschaft christlicher
Influencer/-innen auf Instagram mit.
Als ich mit Leuten aus meinem Umfeld
über mein Thema sprach -
christliche
oder religiöse Influencer -
fragten viele: "Ah, das gibt es?"
Wieso reagieren so viele Leute so?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es überhaupt nicht in das Bild
der Kirche der meisten Leute passt.
Es ist superkonträr zum Sonntag-
morgengottesdienst, den man kennt.
Dort kann man nachweisen, dass
da nur bestimmte Zielgruppen sind.
Es sind
nur bestimmte Altersgruppen da.
Es ist ein sehr neues, ergänzendes
Bild, das die Kirche von sich zeigt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen -
man sieht es auch -,
dass die Follower hauptsächlich aus
diesem kirchlichen Hintergrund sind.
Es hat wohl noch nicht viele Leute
ausserhalb dieser kirchlichen Blase
erreicht.
Ich habe in eurer Studie gelesen,
dass religiöser Instagram-Content
für gewisse Leute der einzige
Kontakt mit der Kirche ist.
Die Studie zeigt interessanterweise,
dass die Follower/-innen v.a.
zwischen 20 und 39 Jahre alt sind.
Das sind genau die Leute, mit denen
sich die Kirche etwas schwer tut,
weil die Kirche für sie
praktisch kein Angebot hat.
Ich würde sagen,
genau deshalb ist Instagram
für die Kirche so interessant.
So kann immerhin versucht werden,
mit den Leuten in Kontakt zu kommen,
für die man sonst
noch nichts Gutes entwickelt hat.
Aber dann stellt sich die Frage:
Funktioniert das Ganze überhaupt?
Was heisst denn funktionieren?
In dem Sinne,
dass neue Leute erreicht werden?
Das weiss ich nicht genau.
Die Studie zeigt z.B.,
dass 85 % der Follower/-innen
schon Kirchenmitglieder sind.
Ich würde aber auch sagen, die Mit-
gliederbindung ist genauso wichtig,
dass die Leute, die sonst kein Ange-
bot haben, hier jetzt eins bekommen,
eine Möglichkeit bekommen,
ihren eigenen Glauben ...
Da inspiriert zu werden
oder Glaubensvorbilder zu bekommen.
In dem Sinne zeigt die Studie, dass
das ein funktionierendes Format ist.
Die Studie besagt, es gibt missio-
narisches Potenzial auf Instagram.
Was bedeutet das?
Diese Studie wurde von
einer Arbeitsstelle durchgeführt,
der Evangelischen Kirche Deutsch-
land, die genau dieses Anliegen hat.
Sie nennen das "missionarisch".
Sie beschreiben es so, dass sie die
eigene Botschaft so kommunizieren,
dass sie für Menschen in unserer mo-
dernen Gesellschaft attraktiv wird.
Genau darum geht es,
dass es Formen gibt, die für Leute,
gerade
diese 20- bis 39-Jährigen cool sind.
Die unabhängig vom Inhalt
ästhetisch ansprechend sind,
sodass man sich damit
irgendwie verbinden kann.
Der Zugang zum Inhalt
wird überhaupt erst ermöglicht.
Natürlich gibt es auch Beispiele,
die ich kritisch sehen würde.
Also wenn seltsame
Geschlechterrollen herrschen
oder - aus meiner Sicht - seltsame
sexual-ethische Vorstellungen
im Hintergrund sind.
Gleichzeitig gibt es auch
ein enorm hohes Potenzial,
weil die Plattform
unglaublich partizipativ ist.
Es ist schon ein bisschen anders
als jetzt ...
Diese gefährlichen Dynamiken haben
wir z.T. in analogen Gemeinden -
je nach Strömung.
Das Schöne ist, auf Instagram kann
man sich als Follower verhalten.
Man kann entfolgen, anderen folgen,
sich eine Pluralität
an Meinungen holen usw.
Man kann sogar kommentieren.
Findet eine theologische Meinung
statt, kann man sich dazu verhalten.
Das ist die enorme Chance dabei.
Vielen Dank für den Call.
Das war's auch schon
von diesem "Q&A".
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen,
bis zum nächsten Mal.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Kira Euler - 2023